[Applause]
that was moving cut the cameras
that's gwen stefani feeling all the
feels and we mean all of them on the
voice that was incredible let me go
right to your coach Gwen oh my god I'm
crying that was unbelievable
I am so in awe of you I'm so honored
[Applause]
like I said all the fields it's been
really inspiring to be around all these
amazing people talented singers here's
what went down during the semi-finals on
Monday night Gwen's contestant row short
belted out a killer performance of I
want to know what love is
dear ma
[Music]
yeah that performance was so good it had
Gwen deep in her feelings so much so
that went host Carson Daly tossed to her
for her feedback she could not get it
together that's why you're crying you're
a gift you are gift okay what happens on
this show you are so blessed please my
favorite part of this whole thing is
definitely Carson narrating Gwen's hug
as Quinn comes over emotional to give
Rose a hug we
focus on JP post-op tonight what a play
by play anyway Gwen also got a little
teary-eyed talking to et before the show
Blake had just opened up to et about his
upcoming duet with Glenn nobody but you
and how it relates to their relationship
I don't want to remember what I was like
before Gwen actually I mean I'm a little
bit of a jerk to you still but I was a
jerk to everybody before Gwen
she changed sheets look how nice I am
now Blake saved my life everybody knows
that like we are just having the time of
our lives and we never expected that at
this late in our lives so we're just
trying to save forever in every moment
together and just to be back here on the
voice as well has been not to change the
subject but like I'm just saying like
together working together again has been
really really fun and I love being here
and I love being with him so it's like
them being on the show together it
brings a nice energy to the show are
your eyes watery I yes who knew what a
softie cute Gwen of course you can count
on et to bring you all the Blake and
Gwen news so make sure to keep it locked
or right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stephens see you soon
[Music]